Chuck and Nancy get memed for their
American Gothic response to president
Trump's oval office speech we will
analyze why responses to presidential
addresses never ever ever work then
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez responds to the
responders President Trump gives the
speech itself you don't want to forget
about that and Kellyanne Conway roasts
Jim Acosta finally the American
Psychological Association declares
masculinity harmful what a bunch of
wimps all of that and more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
all right there's only one news story
today and that would be the Oval Office
speech or really I guess it would be the
response to the Oval Office of speech
their response to the responders and the
memes on Twitter the response to the
responders to the responders on MSNBC in
AOC we'll get to all of that let's cover
the speech first
how did President Trump do first of all
we got full entertainment last night we
got exactly what we came for we we
elected the reality TV show host we are
getting a perfect night of television we
got all of the drama from President
Trump we then got a lot of farcical
comedy probably unintentional comedy
from Chuck and Nancy Schumer and Pelosi
so how did Trump himself do in the
speech I thought he did quite well some
conservatives think that he was too
dramatic here this is the big divide
today in response to the speech on among
conservatives was he too dramatic was he
too gory was he too gruesome or did he
hit it right now that group of
conservatives who broadly are the ones
who were always criticizing Trump or
they were never Trump during the
election they're criticizing President
Trump for being too gruesome talking
about sexual assaults at the border
talking about the crimes of illegal
aliens talking about people whose
children were killed by illegal aliens
what those conservatives who were
criticizing him for that want is they
wish that he was just talking about
dollars and cents what they wish is the
president Trump went out into the Oval
Office speech last night and he was the
reasonable guy hey guys come on it's not
that big a deal the borders not very
expensive he's only asking five billion
and look we spend money on all these
kind of other crazy things we spend
millions of dollars to study shrimp on
treadmills we stat we spend millions of
dollars to study lesbian obesity come on
it's only a very small portion of money
it's not that big a deal and it's just
about dollars and cents and come on guys
come around to it
that is I would call them at that group
the fiscal first conservatives they're
judging their political views and the
conservative movement from the
perspective of dollars and cents
basically this is contrasted with
another group which is the cultural
conservatives and I would count myself
in the latter group the culture
conservatives are the ones who were
saying this isn't about dollars and
cents this isn't about being a
reasonable guy you know and I'm sorry it
is about being a reasonable guy but it's
not about always appearing to be the
most pleasant the least offensive gets
not about that it's about gut issues the
reason that we need to deal with the
border is not just because of some bland
statistics or because of the cost of the
wall or whatever it's because we're a
country and we have the right to be a
country and we have the right to defend
our country every other country in
history has done it we should do it too
real people are being hurt by this real
people are being hurt by drugs pouring
in by gangsters by sexual assaults on
the border all of those things first of
all to begin President Trump is the
cultural figure he's comes out of the
culture he's a TV guy he's been in the
pop culture since at least the 80s I was
playing Trump the board game which came
out in 1989 I was playing that over the
weekend with friends he's been this
cultural maven so he's always gonna be
that guy he's not ever going to become
some policy wonk he's not mitch Daniels
i like mitch daniels too but he's just
not that guy who's gonna be a wonk about
all these different lines of the budget
or something like that isn't going to
happen but in this debate between the
fiscal first conservatives and the
cultural conservatives the cultural
conservatives are right yeah which is
why they're getting this speech right as
well
conservatism we talked about this a
little bit yesterday when we mentioned
Russell Kirk conservatism is not
primarily about dollars and cents there
is there's a kind of that's part of the
conservative movement and especially you
see this among college kids the young
Republican type with the Brooks Brothers
tie who goes to whatever political
dinners and things like that you see
that really about among him he's the one
who's saying let's not talk about
cultural issues let's just talk about
dollars and cents the economy let's only
talk about fiscal and financial
questions conservatism is not primarily
about that it's not primarily about
making a profit conservatism in the
russell kirk understanding of it is
actually primarily about loss it's about
what we've lost in our society it's
about
how how we even as we do gain in many
ways profit we're losing some of our
culture we're losing some of our spirit
we're losing some of the things that
matter much more than just base material
goods
there are metaphysical goods that really
count - this is the Andrew Breitbart
idea of things
politics is downstream of culture st.
Andrew Breitbart the patron saint of
Hollywood conservatives again with that
group of fiscal first conservatives you
see it a lot of times they'll say enough
with the culture war if we would only
stop the culture war get out of cultural
issues then we would win every single
election outside of cultural issues
everything else is bean-counting this is
not to say that we shouldn't lower taxes
this is not to say that we shouldn't
reform entitlements we have to do all of
those things but that is bean-counting
if you don't couch it in a cultural and
moral argument and that's what President
Trump was doing last night it would have
been a huge mistake if he went out there
and just talked about how the wall
wasn't that expensive and come on it's
not that big a deal everybody and let's
just do it and move on that's not what
this is about
the this isn't that big a deal argument
falls flat when you have Democrats
constantly telling you this is the
biggest deal in the world you know when
in politics just like in war your
opponent gets a say your adversary gets
a say about it and they're saying it's a
huge deal therefore it is a huge deal
it's a big deal to them it's a big deal
to the left why not because of five
billion dollars here or there they'll
spend five billion dollars willy-nilly
it's a big deal to them because it cuts
to the heart of their agenda which is
open borders which is tearing down
traditional culture and American
traditions which is essentially anti
Americanism and anti Western ISM that's
their that's their issue and so it's not
about a five billion dollar few hundred
miles of a border wall it's about the
momentum it's about what direction
that's going in that's about what
message that sending which is is America
going to protect itself stand up love
itself keep keep being America or are we
gonna give up on that that's why the
stakes are so high the argument for the
border wall is not that the border wall
is inexpensive
who cares who cares if the border wall
is expensive if the border wall if the
the section of the wall they wanted to
build in this budget if it cost twenty
billion dollars would that change
anyone's position on it let's say cost
fifty billion dollars would it Kanaan it
no no way the argument is we're a
country we get to be a country we don't
want all these drugs pouring in for the
first time now in well I guess the
second year in a row but the first time
in 50 years the average life expectancy
of Americans is decreasing because of
all these drug overdoses and because of
amyl a is a spiritual malaise that's hit
the country and led to an epidemic of
suicide that's what it's about it's
about the real Americans whose kids are
dead because illegal aliens killed them
it's a bet we'll go through some of the
statistics we'll go through some of the
responses to Democrat arguments in just
a minute but we should get off of this
argument that the the argument for the
wall is that it's just and not that
expensive
who cares it's not a bet it's about
something so much deeper and you're not
gonna convince anybody on dollars and
cents your this is well this is why Mitt
Romney couldn't become president and
never will become president is because
you can't campaign for the presidency
and say I should win the presidency at a
time of great cultural gravity because
I'm a better manager who cares and
that's not what we're talking about we
don't I don't care if you're gonna be
slightly more efficient manager than the
other guy we're talking about ideas
we're not talking about efficiency so
let's get to the speech itself here is
part of the where the real disagreement
comes up where the fiscal first
conservatives are saying he went way too
far was focusing in on crime and rape
last month 20,000 migrant children were
illegally brought into the United States
a dramatic increase these children are
used as human pawns by vicious coyotes
and ruthless gangs one in three women
are sexually assaulted on the dangerous
trek up through Mexico women are
children are the biggest victims by far
of our broken system this is the tragic
reality
of illegal immigration on our southern
border this is the right tone obviously
President Trump is better off script he
does better at his rallies he does
better when he's improvising he's ad
libbing but this was pretty good I mean
it was a bleed delivered it was very
well written he delivered it without any
big mistakes I thought it went pretty
well you knew he was reading from a
prompter but presidents are always
reading from teleprompters in these
speeches so I didn't think that was a
big deal
as for the statistic he said one in
three women are raped crossing the
border from Mexico into the u.s. he
actually could have used a bigger
statistic than that there are there are
studies out from fusion and Amnesty
International which show that 60 to 80
percent of women and girls are raped
crossing that border illegally this
wasn't reported in some right-wing outa
this was reported in The Huffington Post
so I felt he should have used that
statistic but again it's very hard to
have reliable statistics on on a degree
of crime that is that is so hidden from
public view still I felt he should have
gone whole hog and used used even the
more powerful statistics which are
backed up by left-wing sources so you
couldn't even have left-wingers argument
with them then he goes on and talks
about those who have been victimized by
illegal aliens the only thing that is
immoral is the politicians to do nothing
and continue to allow more innocent
people to be so horribly victimized
America's heart broke the day after
Christmas when a young police officer in
California was savagely murdered in cold
blood by an illegal alien just came
across the border the life of an
American Hero was stolen by someone who
had no right to be in our country
day after day precious lives are cut
short by those who have violated our
borders in California an Air Force
veteran was raped murdered and beaten to
death with a hammer by an illegal alien
with a long criminal history in Georgia
an illegal alien was recently too
charged with murder for killing
beheading and dismembering his neighbor
this is a pretty brutal stuff I mean
it's it's you've never heard a president
talk about these sorts of things from
the Oval Office
you've never heard after 9/11 President
Bush spoke in very strong terms but he
didn't speak in such graphic terms
president Trump is speaking these
graphic gruesome terms talking about
beheading and some people some people
fairly enough say I don't want to hear
this from the Oval Office
I'm with you I agree in my ideal
politics we would not have these sort of
things said in speeches to the nation
from The Oval Office in my ideal
politics and get when you're giving a
speech to an audience that includes
children old women whatever you're not
going to use this kind of imagery
however we're not living in my ideal
politics in my ideal politics the very
fact of these beheading is the very fact
of these rapes the very fact of these
drugs pouring in across the border would
be enough to compel Democrats half of
the country to just enhance border
security to build a wall to stop people
from doing this to deport gang members
that in my ideal politics in any
reasonable politics that would happen
but it's not happening in fact in in the
reasonable politics of less than 10
years ago Democrats agreed that we could
do that various Democrats actually voted
for proportions of the wall but we don't
live in that ideal politics and this is
the trouble in politics as in war your
opponent gets a say your adversary gets
a saying so you've got to react in real
time it's where I really lose patience
with those Trump critics on the right
who say well in my imaginary world
things would be so much better and I
would never say these mean things and I
would never get down in the mud right
but we don't live in your imaginary
fantasy world we live in reality and the
reality is that if Democrats are going
to degrade the country in such a way and
degrade our politics in such a way that
this kind of graphic imagery this kind
of vulgarity that they're always spewing
is commonplace we must meet them where
they are we must fight them where they
are we must respond to attacks
they come in and we must attack them
where they're vulnerable that's the
culture that's the politics politics is
a practical science it's not theoretical
it's not strictly philosophical it is it
is reality politics is the affairs
between men and so you've got half of
the country wearing simulacra of
genitalia on their heads shrieking
mother effer this and mother effer that
an incoming new member of Congress
Rasheeda Talib saying we're going to
impeach the mother effer in public
referring to the President of the United
States unfortunately when you're in that
disgusting culture you've got to deal
with it in reality and and if the if the
difference is if the two options are
president from sitting there and talking
about how five billion dollars won't
impact the federal budget at all because
the entire debt and deficit is driven by
entitlements and Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid if that's one
option and then the other option is
they're using disgusting graphic imagery
to talk about why the wall is wrong I'm
gonna use it to explain the true imagery
to explain why it's right because people
are being beheaded people are being
killed by drugs people are being raped
that is what we have to do reality can
be pretty gory sometimes but you should
you should speak the truth even if the
truth is unpleasant if if the if the way
to persuade people is to tell them the
truth and you can do it in a more
diplomatic way sometimes you can do it
in a more civilized way sometimes where
you have to be blunt sometimes we're in
a very blunt culture a very authentic
raw culture this isn't only the
Democrats fault this is just the fact of
our media landscape we're constantly on
social media where it's it's raw and
it's live and people make mistakes and
you no longer elect a movie actor like
Ronald Reagan you elect a reality TV
actor like Donald Trump that is
reflective of the culture and I think he
handled it very very well so let's take
a look at the reality of this by the way
if we're gonna delve into the how
gruesome this is now you're hearing the
left saying oh these these stories of
illegal alien crime they're lies they're
not true I think Nancy Pelosi called it
malice and misinformation it isn't there
was just what a Breitbart did just one
quick rundown
of ms-13 specifically crimes in the last
couple years last year an ms-13 gangster
pimp ordered the baseball bat beating of
a 15 year old prostitute in Maryland a
20 17 year before an ms-13 gangster
stabbed a Maryland man 100 times
beheaded him and cut out his heart
that's the kind of people we're talking
about that's the kind of crime that is
encouraged across this border if you if
you create incentives for them to come
over 2017 ms-13 murder to new york teen
girls 2016 year before ms-13 murdered a
14 year old texas boy with a machete
there was all spate of machete crimes
attributed to ms-13 that's the reality
that the Democrats are saying Nancy
Pelosi said this during her response she
said mr. president women and girls at
the border they don't pose a threat to
us right yeah we're not we're not
worried about the women and children
we're worried about that guy we're
worried about the drugs that are that
are coming over in such a large quantity
that the average American life
expectancy is decreasing we're worried
about the threats to our own sovereignty
as a country because illegal aliens are
counted as population for the
distribution of a congressman in the
House of Representatives because they're
counted by the census we're worried
about illegal alien voting which does
happen we're worried about illegal
aliens not just committing crimes but
also stressing our resources a illegal
aliens are much more likely to access
welfare programs obviously than citizens
and of course just accessing regular
regular old government entitlements like
public education is a huge stress to the
system for people who have not been
allowed in here you're they are they're
taking a free ride and the people who
are very generous people the most
generous country in all of human history
the people are who were being demanded
to pay for that don't even get a say in
it it's it's outrageous and that's the
language you've got to use so what did
this speech accomplish there was a
question before the speech as to whether
or not President Trump would declare a
national emergency and what this would
do by declaring a national emergency was
it would give him the ability without
Congress giving
the five billion dollars to build
portions of the wall and he could order
this to be done for the Pentagon or
through other mechanisms but he could
have gotten that done this would have
been drastic it would have had huge
legal challenges it it definitely would
have absorbed a lot of the air out of
2019 and a lot of the political capital
out of 2019 should he have done it
should he not have done it possibly he
should have because President Trump does
very well with adversaries and he does
very well in unconventional politics
still I think the reason why he didn't
do it is because we're in this very
strange moment where the wall is
unpopular the wall if he had declared a
national emergency to build the wall
this would not have done well in public
opinion polls but what does that mean so
the wall is unpopular however border
security is very popular and you'll even
see this within the same poll there was
a poll out from Harvard Harris obviously
very reputable poll it showed that that
Americans don't want the wall they want
to give amnesty to to daca to the
illegal aliens brought here when they
were under 18 also they want to end
chain migration also they don't just
want to stop illegal immigration they
want to dramatically reduce levels of
legal immigration so right now our rate
of legal immigration is about 1.2 1.3
million people per year pouring into
this country the Harvard Harris poll
shows the majority of Americans want to
reduce that by more than 50% bring it
down to about half a million immigrants
coming into the country per year so how
do you make sense of that they say we
were so against immigration at this
point we don't just want to stop illegal
immigration we want to lower legal
immigration also you can't build a wall
we don't want you to build a wall now
what this speaks to is one obviously how
questions are worded can change this but
it speaks to political messaging the
Democrats have focused in on this wall
issue and they focused in on personality
so the wall is identified with Donald
Trump and his often acerbic personality
and so they don't like the wall but on
the issue itself they do strongly
work the issue if this is a personality
battle then how did it shake out last
night
I'm not saying president Trump has gets
a hundred percent percentage points on
this I'm not saying he's totally popular
he's not he is polarizing that's been
his appeal all along it's the reason why
he won the Republican nomination it's
not because he's so likable it's not cuz
he has that fake plastic smile on his on
his face like MIT Romney it's because
he's polarizing and he makes stands that
can be unpopular and this makes him more
popular among other demographics but if
it's a personality battle between Donald
Trump and Chuck and Nancy come on that's
not is that even a question is the
obviously president Trump wins that
personality battle Chuck and Nancy will
get to Chuck and Nancy in a second here
is some of the reaction to President
Trump not from Chuck and Nancy not from
Ocasio Cortes just a regular old
backbencher senator Senator Chris Van
Hollen on MSNBC well I have to agree
with Steve that this is a continuation
of the degradation degradation of the
Oval Office by the president ID states
this time using the tradition of Oval
Office speeches that are usually
reserved for major statements instead
for a tawdry political speech I mean
usually it takes the president 55
minutes at a rally to get out all those
lies and false statements this time he
crammed it into eight minutes by reading
a teleprompter lies and fault what lies
and false statements did President Trump
say did he say any because I saw this
going all around Twitter all of the
Talking Heads were chattering about this
said it was all these lies
misinformation malice false statements
what false statements he's won that
they're claiming is that President Trump
President Trump said that thousands of
illegal aliens come in per day they say
that the reality is more like hundreds
in reality it's more like thousands we
have at least a thousand people coming
in over the border every single day and
in recent months DHS itself has been
reporting that they've seized 3,000
illegal aliens in one day so that's not
a lie that's the reality the demo
Grint line is the lie we have over a
thousand people coming into this country
illegally every day and we don't really
know how many there are anyway we're
having that number arrested apprehended
how many people are sneaking through how
many people are not being arrested he
talked about how drugs are pouring
through this country look around look
around in just about any County in
America the drug epidemic has gotten so
awful
that it has lowered the average life
expectancy of Americans you can't deny
that you can't deny that that's not a
lie you can't Democrats are very good at
claiming that false the true statements
are lies who are you gonna believe
Democrats are your own lyin eyes you can
see it all happening around you and you
can see it in even how long Americans
are expected to live and what about the
crisis they say that President Trump
calling the the border security question
a crisis is lie and they say it's a lie
because illegal immigration right now is
not the worst it's ever been well that's
that's quite a definition of crisis oh
if it's not the single worst thing
that's ever happened in this category
then it's not a crisis it's true it's
not as bad as when you had million
people more than a million people coming
in and in the year 2000 it's but you
know it's maybe it's not as bad as that
it's pretty bad and and the other thing
is you can't just freeze one year in
time because when Republicans were
talking about illegal immigration during
during 1980
Bush running for the presidency against
Ronald Reagan they were both debating
illegal immigration and they were both
debating who was more compassionate they
were all saying who's gonna give more
amnesty who's more whatever right at
that time how many illegal aliens were
there in the country not very many but
net but over time when you have a year
after a year after year were it's pretty
bad but it's not a crisis it's just
pretty bad year after year after year
for 30 40 years all of a sudden you get
230 million illegal aliens again we
don't really know how many there are but
could be estimated around 2030 million
illegal aliens who knows so I don't see
any lies also such a such a treat to
listen to a Democrat Senator talking
about the degradation of the Oval Office
bill clinton the not the last democrat
president but the one before him bill
clinton who all the democrats were
campaigning to make the first gentlemen
of the united states just a little over
two years ago bill clinton turned his
intern into a human humidor in the oval
office in that act it wasn't broadcast
on national television mirabile dictu
but he did it there are we really gonna
say that donald trump spouting accurate
information about illegal immigration
that's the degradation of the oval
office
more than trotting in your little
twenty-year-old secretary i don't think
so we've got a lot more to get to we got
to get to chuck in Nancy's response we
got to get to all the great memes
Alexandria cassia Cortes the roast of
Jim Acosta and why masculinity is so
harmful according to all those wimps at
the American Psychological Association
but first we've got a second bite of
Facebook and YouTube and by the way
before we go it's time for you to get on
the right side of history which is in
fact the title of Ben Shapiro's new book
I can assure you this book will be the
second best book out of the last few
years it will be I'm serious I read it I
really enjoyed it I think it's a very
good book and it will be the second best
book to be published since 2017
I'm guarantee it get on the right side
of history it officially hit stores
March 19th but if you go to right side
of history calm you can order your copy
right now before they sell out do it
you'll thank me later it really is good
uh you know I read all of these popular
books that come out on politics or
economics or philosophy I get all of
these advanced copies and I read the I
read most of them and this is the best
one that's come out recently it's just
really good it's a it's a good response
to this very shallow political and
intellectual culture that we're in right
now and it's a good primer if you've
been deprived of an education which if
you are a millennial or Jenn's ear in
America you certainly have been so
definitely go out and preorder it
subscribe to The Daily wire it's ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me at the end reclaim
ensure you get the Ben Shapiro show
Eunice questions the mailbag coming up
tomorrow get your questions in you get
the Matt Walsh show you get to ask
questions backstage you get another
Kingdom you
who get everything and you get this you
get the Chuck and Nancy special edition
this is the one that because what you're
gonna do you'll you'll see the clips of
the response video right after this and
you're gonna put your you're gonna put
that tumbler right up to the screen and
you're gonna watch as those frowny pouty
desiccated faces just pour there they're
not a lot of Tears because that's a
little desiccated but just little little
sore almost powdered drops of leftist
tears into your tumbler and then you can
enjoy them and they're very very
delicious go to daily wire.com we'll be
right back
so President Trump gives his speech
Chuck and Nancy for some reason give a
response I think this is unprecedented
to have a a partisan response to an oval
office address to the nation but you
know that's the Democrats for you this
response did not go well this is not me
being a partisan or biased or it did not
nobody thought this thing went well
Brian Williams on MSNBC made fun of them
we'll get to all of that first just a
little taste of what you missed I hope
you're watching I hope you're not
listening to this I hope you get to see
that looks on their faces otherwise I'll
describe it to you
Thank You Speaker Pelosi my fellow
Americans we address you tonight for one
reason only the President of the United
States having failed to get Mexico to
pay for his ineffective unnecessary
border wall it goes on and on and on
we'll get to more of what they say in a
second it just doesn't look good it
they're they're doing that thing which a
lot of times happens in responses which
is that you just look really angry you
just look super ticked off and it's so
off-putting it doesn't accomplish
anything none of these people have a
gift for show business shockingly
politics is show business for ugly
people they just don't seem to
understand how that comes off on camera
but responses never look good they never
look good and this is a real question if
they asked me tomorrow to give the
Republican response to well I guess we'd
have to wait for a Democrat president
hopefully not until I'm 70 or 80 years
old if that but if they asked me to do
it for a Democrat president I would turn
it down I would laugh in their face it's
a worse job than hosting the Oscars why
why do they look like this why before
before we get to why the responses can't
ever work I guess why didn't this
response work maybe that'll that'll lead
us there the reason this response didn't
work in particular is because Chuck
Schumer is caught between his radical
base which favors open borders and the
Emir
can people which is quite
anti-immigration it's actually anti
current levels of legal immigration and
he's really caught here if you don't
believe me that the Democrat base favors
open borders just look at their campaign
slogans they wanted to abolish ice
Immigration and Customs Enforcement the
the caravan that they were applauding
it's called way below sin Fronteras
Without Borders they're they're
constantly trying to give illegal aliens
access to American services blur the
distinction between citizens and
non-citizens they're constantly trying
to give amnesty which is which is open
borders they're constantly encouraging
more illegal immigration it stems from
an anti Americanism but that's what they
want they want open borders and the
majority the American people do not
Chuck Schumer knows this Chuck Schumer
actually talked about that and not that
long ago Chuck Schumer was talking about
how important it is for us to secure the
border but we also need to set the
record straight the American people need
to know that because of our efforts in
Congress our border is far more secure
today than it was when we began debating
comprehensive reform in 2005 between
2005 and 2009 a vast amount of progress
has been made on our borders and ports
of entry the progress includes 9,000 new
Border Patrol feel eight field agents in
the last four years construction of a
630 mile border fence or 630 miles of
border fence that create a significant
barrier to illegal immigration on our
southern land border so there is
bragging about building a wall bragging
about how great that is
isn't it so we've got him here basically
contradicting himself and that's why he
had to looks a little more stoic and try
to focus on other issues and it just
fell flat there wasn't a clear message
that came out of this the real problem
for them though is not even the logical
progression of their response the real
problem as always being the optics is
they just got memed they got memed so
hard here's one of my favorite versions
of American Gothic Chuck and Nancy
giving their their response
fellow Americans we address you tonight
for one reason only the President of the
United States having failed to get
Mexico in effect unnecessary
[Music]
give me that countryside if you can't
see it she's wearing a little bonnet you
know he's got the he's got the pitchfork
and that's what it looked like it had
this very look of American American
Gothic then there's this then there is
the problem also which we do have to
address of they have conflicting
statements on this so Chuck in Nancy
Nancy's calling the wall immoral Chuck
Schumer voted for the wall already he
voted for part of a wall a few years ago
not that not that long ago
then there's confusion over Democrat
messaging because they're saying that
the wall is immoral and they're also
saying that the wall is ineffective but
it can't be both things at once
so if a if the wall is ineffective why
is it immoral it's not keeping anybody
out it's not doing anything it's letting
these immigrants and illegal aliens come
through that it doesn't really matter at
all if the wall is immoral how is it
ineffective if if something is immoral
it is having a moral effect it is it may
by definition it is effective and so
they can't do this i this reminds me of
all the times when we were arguing over
whether it was okay to torture
terrorists whether which which it is by
the way but the question they would
always argue on the Democrat side you
say is it okay to torture terrorists and
they would say well torturing terrorists
is immoral it's not who we are it's
wrong it's terrible it's immoral and
it's ineffective all right then what's
the big what's the big deal it's not you
know if it's in a femme who cares right
but because they didn't want to
actually deal in the issue we'll do an
episode someday on why it's a very very
very good thing to torture terrorists we
unfortunately we don't have time to do
that now but they've just got this
confused messaging they would be much
smarter to pick a lane and then just try
to advance that lane but but again they
can't because they're torn between their
base which is for open borders and the
American people which is anti illegal
immigration so if they if they pick the
ineffective line then their base is
gonna say what do you I don't care that
it's ineffective I'm glad it's
ineffective but you shouldn't do it in
the first place and then if you say it's
it's immoral
then you alienate the majority of the
country so they're trying to split the
baby it just doesn't work don't take my
word for how bad this response was
obviously you see the memes going around
Twitter here is a no less a Democrat
than James Carville Democrat strategist
on no less a Democrat than Brian
Williams is show on MSNBC giving his
response but tell me why responses are
so bad tonight this Chuck and Nancy
visual tonight launched a thousand memes
while they were still talking there was
an American Gothic meme there was a your
mother and I are very upset you you
stayed out so late name and and someone
has to account for Bobby Jindal his
guest appearance in Gone with the Wind
and for Rubio drinking water but this
visual from tonight goes down in the
pantheon what is the problem with
responses James I you know they seldom
if ever work at the State of the Union
usually get some young person to respond
they tried that with Jindal that didn't
work very well I yeah I don't think they
wanted to do it I don't think they
should have done it and I guarantee at
the staff meeting tomorrow morning
somebody is gonna get you know shoot out
pretty good the only good thing about it
it didn't matter they could have given
to Gettysburg Address and it wasn't
about it it didn't it was different he
didn't want to be I've been more excited
about colonoscopies and he wasn't a
speech tonight
classic jet James Carville as subtlety
but absolutely right
they didn't want to be there it was a
mistake
it was it was a mistake too because
because they have conflicting messages
about this it would have been much
better to let trump go out there be
aggressive be gruesome be graphic in his
language and then just let let the
Democrat anger at him boil over I don't
think the response accomplished anything
for them I hope I hope this speech
accomplished something for Trump in the
Republicans it seems that it didn't so
much as it made the case once and for
all and now we can have basically an
honest debate but you know it didn't
didn't get us the wall right away it
didn't declare a national emergency and
it was probably unwise for the Democrats
to respond in that way they're not the
only ones who respond at our favorite
socialist from that ritzy town in
Northern Westchester Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes gave a response as well on my
program on MSNBC not only that but in
the actual address there was falsehood
after falsehood and we have to make sure
that we get our facts straight every day
immigrants commit crimes at a far lower
rate than native-born Americans and not
only that but the women and children on
that border that are trying to seek
refuge and seek opportunity in the
United States of America with nothing
but the shirt on their backs are acting
more American than any person who seeks
to keep them out ever will be so that
was obviously on my MSNBC program the
Rachel Maddow Show last night where to
begin first of all she's complaining
about President Trump getting the facts
wrong two days ago she was explaining
how you shouldn't be factually correct
how it could be morally wrong to be
factually correct she said that in a
tweet so she's really changing her tune
but that's always what she does
the first observation Nancy Pelosi has a
really tough case here on her hands
because Alexandria ocasion Cortes thinks
that she's the Speaker of the House and
for all intents and purposes she is she
is right now a leading national Democrat
she's the brightest star of the incoming
Democrat congressman and she's causing
real headaches for Nancy Pelosi Congress
members very often are just glorified
press secretaries very few of them know
anything about public policy very few of
them are interested in crafting public
policy most of them just want to go on
television and run for a higher office
so that's what they do they just go on
telling me I mean this is sort of the
Schumer model though Schumer to his
credit does have a lot of acumen and
navigating the halls of government since
he's been in it his entire life and so
if Alexandra of Cassie Cortez is doing
that I mean she's spending all of her
time on TV when she's not on TV she's on
Instagram live when she's not on
Instagram live she's doing videos on
Facebook I mean it's just on and on
she's putting herself out there and but
what she's saying isn't true the trouble
is that she has it sort of sounds like
she's saying true things she's getting
much better at the camera you can see
this even just in her eyes her eyes are
less buggy and weird than they used to
be and they I don't know she's just
getting much smoother and she can say
things with such confidence now she
didn't used to be able to do this she
used to say I'm not the expert haha
sorry now she says untrue things with
such confidence that they're actually
somewhat convincing so she's saying that
illegal alien criminals trying to cross
into our country illegally are more
American than American citizens what
does that even mean
that that doesn't mean that's that the
semantic value of that sentence is but
remember remember but it because she's
saying it with such confidence it sounds
like it means something and they do this
all the time I mean this is another
example of having talked about having
crossed messaging on the one hand
America is a terrible awful racist
bigoted sexist place that has caused
wickedness and evil all throughout the
world on the other hand these illegal
aliens are more American than Americans
well could they keep them out please
don't know don't let them in they sound
like terrible people but of course
they're just trying to say both think
they will just speak out of both sides
of their mouth whatever is most
convenient they will say American can be
the worst adjective in the world it can
connote the most evil that you can
imagine or it can be the most wonderful
thing but but again only when it's
referring to non Americans anyway she's
getting very good as a press secretary
this
is a little bit worrisome and it's
worrisome for Pelosi before we go we've
got to get to Kellyanne Conway I don't
we'll get to the other stuff later I
we've got to get to Kellyanne Conway
this her this had been building for so
long she was there speaking to Jim
Acosta
CNN's Geum Acosta ever heard of him his
name is Jim Acosta he she's there
speaking to him and he's being a glib
little jerk and you can tell this has
just been building and she just lets off
on him its glorious enjoy can you
promise that the president will tell the
truth tonight will he tell the truth
yesterday man can you promise that you
will hold to do nothing but the truth so
help you God make sure that goes viral
okay this is why by the way this is why
I'm one of the only people around here
moving gives you the time of day can you
get back in your face because you're
such a smart ass most of the time and I
know you want this to go viral a lot of
these people don't like you but let me
just be respectful to the media at large
as I always am I explained that that was
alternative information additional facts
and I explained it many times and don't
you put it back in my face for all the
corrections that your network needs to
issue I was on your network 25 or 26
times in 2018 and one of the last people
here who even bothered to go on and the
disrespect that you showed in me
personally I'll just live pass preach
preach Gillian oh that was just so
beautiful it was devastating and this is
because Kelly and Conway is much much
much more intelligent than Jim Acosta
and and this is the point I want to make
here specifically Jim Acosta says to her
as a sort of just insult he says will
you talk about alternative facts Kelly
this has become a slogan on the left
about how Republicans and conservatives
don't value the truth we value
alternative facts alternative facts was
a phrase uttered by Kellyanne Conway in
a very specific context which is
perfectly reasonable and actually tells
you something very truthful just in case
you don't remember it here's the clip
you do not answer the question of why
the president asked
the White House press secretary to come
out in front of the podium for the first
time and utter a falsehood why did he do
that it undermines the credibility of
the entire White House press office so
don't be so overly dramatic about it
chuckle what it you're saying it's a
falsehood and they're giving the Sean
Spicer our press secretary gave
alternative facts to that but the point
is alternative acts yes alternative
facts this isn't crazy the the the left
because they're not very good at
language they're very good at perverting
language but they're not very good at
understanding language alternative is an
alternative it's not opposite facts it's
not that the fact is a falsehood it's an
alternative fact meaning and another
fact here's another fact so what the
Sean Spicer had said was that more
people watched Trump's inauguration than
any inauguration in history that's true
what the Democrats said was there the
crowd sizes in Washington were smaller
than Obama's that might be true that
maybe that's true
the alternative fact is that millions
and millions of more people watched on
social media on Instagram on snapchat on
media that did not exist for Barack
Obama's first inauguration or or many
that didn't exist for a second
inauguration there are facts here are
some alternative facts to give you
context and to let you see the whole
picture it's it's evidence again that
all shallows are clear and Democrats and
left-winger is thinking in a very
shallow way think that they've got Trump
on this on this issue is so clear and
this issue is so clear and there's no
other side to the issue there is there's
an alternative side and if you look at
the alternative side then you'll get the
whole picture and you can hopefully form
a serious opinion in this serious
conclusion but the the left wing has
abandoned that for now in place of
slogans and and ridiculous memes that at
least give us some enjoyment during the
day all right that's our show we have so
much more to get to but too bad we'll do
it tomorrow get your mailbag questions
in I'm Michael nose this is the Michael
no show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael noland is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Jim nickel audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jeshua alvera the Michael Knowles show
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2018